to begin we need to distinguish two
ideas that are often muddled often
confused
the first
is the idea of Merit in the sense of
competence
that's a good thing
the second is meritocracy
that's a problem
if I need surgery I want a
well-qualified surgeon to perform it if
I'm flying
in an airplane I want a well-qualified
pilot
in the cockpit aligning people's skills
with the jobs that and social roles they
perform
that's that's a good thing unsensible
practical grounds
but that's not meritocracy
meritocracy is something different
meritocracy is an ethic
of earning and deserving it's a system
of rule
based on deservingness
by a system of rule I mean a way of
allocating income and wealth power honor
esteem
the meritocratic ideal can be summed up
in a simple proposition
if chances are equal
the winners
deserve their winnings
notice this is a moral claim it goes
well beyond the Practical proposition
that it's a good thing to have
well-qualified surgeons and airline
pilots
now this is really the heart the moral
argument is really the heart of the case
for meritocracy if one can be made
and it arises
typically in the following Way by asking
the question
what was wrong with a feudal aristocracy
a hereditary aristocracy or a class
based society
and there are two answers to this
question the first is a practical
objection
hereditary aristocracies
were inefficient
because those who landed on top
May well had been incompetent meanwhile
there were many gifted talented people
serfs peasants harvesting potatoes
that's the Practical objection the
objection of inefficiency
but the second objection
to a class-based society or an Aristotle
hereditary aristocracy is the moral
objection
it's unfair
why is it unfair because people's life
prospects are determined in a hereditary
aristocracy by the accident of birth
and when that's the case
it can't really be said that those who
land on top deserve their place they
don't deserve their place
because it's not their doing they
haven't earned it
they've lucked into it
so that's what's wrong with a feudal or
hereditary aristocracy meritocracy seems
to offer a solution to this problem if
careers are open to talents and if
everyone has an equal chance to develop
their talents then it can be said so the
meritocrat argues that the winners
deserve their winnings
but can it be said that the winners in a
meritocracy deserve their winnings no
not really for two reasons
first is to do with differences in
upbringing family background the second
is to do with talents
even if everyone can attend a good
school
even if everyone is free to take
University entrance exams
still it's the case that those from
supportive families are likely to do
better
and we see this today
in
most in American universities most of
the students
at selective colleges and universities
in the United States are from affluent
families very few from poor backgrounds
if you look at the hundred or so most
competitive universities in the United
States more than 70 percent of those who
attend come from the top quarter of the
income scale
how many from the bottom quarter
three percent
if you look at the most prestigious
places the ivy league and Stanford in
such places
there are more students from the top one
percent
than from families in the bottom half of
the country combined put it another way
if you come from a rich family in the
top one percent your chances of
attending an Ivy League school are 77
times greater than if you come from a
poor family and this is despite generous
financial aid to those from poor
backgrounds
so this is one problem now you might say
well the solution to this problem is
simply more meritocracy improve
educational opportunity for low-income
students so they can compete on a Level
Playing Field
yes by all means we should do that
but
that but suppose that we could suppose
that we could somehow counteract it's
unlikely
counteract all of the advantages of
family background in meritocratic
competition
then what
then
hypothetically whoever did best on
objective tests
standardized tests aptitude tests like
the American sat
they would win admission
but because those tests would then truly
measure Talent
IQ intellectual promise
but that raises a further question
because remember we're talking about
moral deservingness
why do The Talented the gifted it's
defined even by the best IQ test you
could imagine
why did they deserve
the winnings that that would flow to
them in a meritocratic uh competitive
Society
is there having an IQ a high IQ or is
their ability to do well on standardized
tests is that they're doing or is that
their Good Fortune
there are two contingencies to do with
the way talents could be rewarded
first having this or that Talent
is not one's own doing think of a great
athlete like Ronaldo or Lionel Messi or
Wayne Rooney
having the talent great athletic Talent
that's a gift
second the fact that these great
footballers live in a society that loves
football that's not their doing that too
is their good luck had Ronaldo lived
back in the days of the Renaissance they
didn't care much about football they
were more interested in Fresco painting
so these are two elements of moral
contingency
that undermine the idea that the The
Talented if we could identify them
somehow uh without any class bias that
The Talented deserve all the benefits
that flow from the exercise their talent
so here's the question it's a question
for Adrian
a question for any defender of
meritocracy
what is the difference
morally
between the accident of birth
of being born
to a well-off family
or in the upper class
and the accident of birth involved in
being born gifted or with the talents
Society happens to prize
if someone happens to be born with a
high IQ
are they any more deserving
than someone who happens to be born
into the upper class
that's the question for Adrian and I'm
eager to hear what he has to say